it's very lovely to be here thanks for
having me I'm actually a little bit
miffed that the space is so nice I had
to walk through the construction that
was this for two years and then I
graduated before we actually got to use
any of the very wonderful facilities but
it's nice to be back so we'll start with
a little bit about me and how I ended up
here I grew up in the Bay Area
both my parents were software engineers
PhD is a computer science seem very
obvious that I was going to walk down
this path in tech I came to Stanford not
exactly knowing what I wanted to do but
thinking maybe computer science or
something something in this domain she
surprisingly it was not that
straightforward for me when I took my
first couple of courses in computer
science I was intimidated and decided to
not major in CS and it was she was why I
ended up doing Electrical Engineering
because I felt like it's still technical
but at least no one has been programming
EE circuit since they were eight the way
it felt like many of my classmates and
computer science had been so I switched
over into Electrical Engineering decided
I didn't like that at all and so I was
trying to figure out my way out of a E
and only ended up majoring in computer
science because one of my friends had
essentially dared me to do it I knew I
was gonna do a CO term like a great deal
to get a master's degree with only one
extra year and I've been thinking of
doing it in some other field mainly
because I was chickening out of doing
something technical and my friend dared
me so that's how I ended up doing EE and
computer science at Stanford and he was
just very lucky to be here in the valley
ended up doing some pretty cool
internships but also very
unintentionally so I wandering around
the career fairs at Stanford ran into
Google and Facebook at the and hosting
their their booths and mainly just to
get the free gifts from these companies
had to turn in my resume and that turned
into getting the
internships it's a very unintentional
path even though I had grown up here I
still didn't quite know what I wanted to
do and wasn't very confident in my
direction it was very fortunate to be
connected to the Mayfield Fellows
program through a number of friends I
had gone through it and that was my
entree into the world of actual startups
Silicon Valley entrepreneurship and so
when I graduated I was debating where I
should go I was thinking of doing one of
the big tech companies is very cool to
go work at Google or Facebook but having
just done Mayfield I thought I should
maybe give the startup thing ago and
ended up joining Quora the question and
answer site back then it was only four
people so I was a fifth person to join
the T and this was pre-funding
super-early ultimately I decided it was
worth the shot it wasn't really that
risky as a software engineer I figured
if it went out of business I would just
go be a software engineer somewhere else
and that was an amazing ride at kora I
actually discovered what it means to be
a software engineer which I somehow
hadn't learned despite getting two
degrees in engineering from Stanford it
wasn't until I was actually on the
ground building a product at kora that I
realized how fun it was to be building
but at the same time there was something
that felt a little bit off and I hadn't
identified it when I was in school or
even during my internships but just
something felt wrong and about a year
into working full-time I seriously
questioned whether I should be in tech
even though I loved coding I loved
building products I just felt like I
didn't belong and I didn't know what it
was until I realized that maybe I had
something to do with gender and my
identity of who I am and I looked around
me the industry there were just not a
lot of other women and that realization
started to kick in I started to see that
there were actually potentially systemic
issues and for the longest time I think
I didn't want to realize this because
Silicon Valley is so bought into this
idea of the meritocracy and the people
with these shiny degrees and who are the
startup founder
and success stories these people will
deserve it because they're the best and
the best people always succeed and the
people who are succeeding are the best
people and I was very fortunate to have
some of these markers of privilege and
these credentials I had two degrees from
Stanford and technical fields I'd done
all the right internships so I wanted to
believe like I deserve my success I
wanted to believe in this system of
meritocracy so it was a pretty rough
realization for me that the system isn't
fair and a little bit embarrassing to
think on how late I was to become woke
to this idea like I didn't participate
in women's groups in college and I
wasn't particularly aware of feminism or
social justice or any of these things
the way I try to control myself about
this now is that if I weren't
embarrassed but where I was ten years
ago I haven't been growing enough but it
was a pretty belated realization at the
same time so this is concurrently
working at Quora because it is this
user-generated content site we needed a
lot of content on Quora
all of us as early employees also wrote
a lot of answers just to try to make the
site seem more interesting and one of
the few topics of like I could write
confidently about was my experience
being a woman in engineering a woman in
tech so inadvertently started becoming
more vocal on the subject just because
we were trying to fill the site with
content and it was a really great
experience to to hear from other people
who would write back to me privately and
say thank you so much for voicing these
experiences like I'm not in a position
where I can write about these issues but
I feel the same way and I also heard
from people who are not women in
engineering but a black person and
tagged who said you know it's not quite
the same but there are also no other
people that look like me in the room and
I tried to see much more like how
prevalent these patterns of
marginalization are so those I guess the
beginning of my starting to become woke
journey after quarry I went to Pinterest
Pinterest was also very small when I
joined was about
ten people so again very fun startup
journey for a while when I was at
Pinterest I just wanted to focus on the
engineering side we were scaling like
crazy we're doubling the user base every
month and a half so we just had plenty
of work to do and I was much more
focused on building out the startup
engineering side of things but one thing
that was really remarkable much about my
time at Pinterest was that it was the
first place I felt like I was treated as
a software engineer and not a female
software engineer and that was a really
big realization to me because I had
never known before what it would feel
like to be treated this way
even when I was in school there was no
overt discrimination but being one of
only it's like two women in a computer
science classroom it did feel weird for
example if I was sleeping in class the
professor would always know if I stood
out a little bit too much but I always
felt there was something unusual about
being a woman and all these spaces that
I was in and I Pinterest was the first
time I felt like I was treated as an
engineer first so that was a really nice
revelation to have and so also
encouraged by that culture at Pinterest
I started again to pick up some of the
discussion of diversity issues and in
2013 as Tina mentioned I wrote a medium
post calling out the diversity industry
about its lack of data the technology
industry about its lack of data about
diversity and the origin of this was
that I had gone to the Grace Hopper
conference which is this like big
conference every year annual celebration
of women in computing now it's over
10,000 people that go back then it was a
little bit smaller and I had heard
Sheryl Sandberg talking about how dire
the situation was for women in
technology how the numbers was robbing
precipitously and I just realized that
there weren't any numbers and it was so
ironic that being in an industry that's
so data-driven that we didn't have data
on diversity as an engineer I had had to
build out a be testing framework I'd
instrument every product launch I had
done we pour it over the metrics to all
these dashboards it's because we cared
about those things and we wanted to
optimize them
the fact that there was no data on
diversity signaled to me that we were
trying to hide the problem or minimize
it and we weren't actually serious about
solving it and so this medium post I
wrote was just a call as a question it
was a call to action and I didn't really
expect anybody to respond to it but
surprisingly a lot of people followed up
and send in their numbers around women
in engineering I still run this
repository and people still submit their
data but some of the key learnings there
to me were that people actually did care
and just didn't know what to do but
giving them a very concrete action item
which was count up your number of women
in engineering count up your total
number of Engineers and submit that
someplace so we can start building a
benchmark that very easy concrete action
people were very happy to take it they
just didn't know what to do before and
that ended up kick-starting that whole
wave of disclosures where Google called
up in May of 2014
Facebook LinkedIn Microsoft Apple like
all these companies are now in the
pattern of releasing annual diversity
data reports which is pretty cool
unfortunately the numbers have not been
very good in the last five years so now
oftentimes people ask me like so great
did this thing in 2013 like where are we
in 2018 how much has happened in the
last five years and sad thing is there
hasn't been a ton of progress there's
very slow progress and the numbers and
percentages of women in engineering a
lot of VC firms have in the past year
hire their first female partners so
there's a little bit of progress there
there's been some backsliding on racial
diversity so this nonprofit ascend has
done some analysis of this and seen that
while white women in leadership have
increased our percentages every other
ethnicity has lost ground in leadership
so we're backsliding there there's a lot
of talk about diversity and it's getting
more nuanced but it hasn't gone much
beyond that some of the things that are
nice to see in that discussion diversity
is that we are starting to talk about
diversity is more than just gender and
more than just white women for example
we're talking about diversity and
inclusion no longer just diversity but
thinking about once you have different
people in the room do you actually
incorporate everyone's opinions and
allow everyone the same chances to
succeed we've started to advance some of
our terminology around things like gas
lighting which I didn't realize what's
happening to me but this idea of making
people feel like they're crazy and that
things are in their head when they talk
about these issues when I first started
talking about being female and tech and
maybe having a different experience and
the men around me I was told that there
was no sexism and just because I
believed that there were sexism I was
projecting it around me now I know that
there was a term for this which is gas
lighting and it's good that we're trying
to advance some of the vocabulary we
could start to identified these things
and make progress around them some other
things that have happened the last few
years is more of a spotlight on BC the
venture capitalists and not just on the
tech companies which is good they're
very important part of the ecosystem B
C's are the ones that decide who started
up ideas even get a chance to you know
to try to make it but unfortunately I
think some of what's happened with all
the discussion of diversity is that it's
turned into diversity as PR or theater
sometimes diversity is used as a way to
get deal flow and B C's which is
unfortunate at the same time I do think
it's better that people at least say
that they care about diversity rather
than not saying that they care so at
least it's the general trend that people
will say it's diversity is a good thing
and hopefully we can just start to close
that gap between what is said and what
is done some of the things that have
happened in terms of like where people
are saying these pledges is it's not
very in vogue to have pledges the white
house did a big coalition with a bunch
of tech companies in 2016
asking them to pledge to have goals
around recruitment and retention and
promotion of minorities and and women
and to release their diversity
data and to build partnerships to
increase the pipeline so like about 80
companies signed onto this pledge was
like your great press thing in 2016 and
a year later only 17 of the firms had
actually followed throughout anything so
there's still a little bit of tendency
for people to say nice things and not
actually follow through which is
something we'll have to to counter
there's also trying to be some backlash
so the New York Times ran some articles
recently a few months ago about how the
men in tech think it's gone too far and
some of you may know about the Google
engineer who wrote a memo last summer
talking about how the diversity efforts
were misguided I was not a huge fan of
his argument but there were a number of
men who were very glad that he was
giving voice to some of these opinions
that he had I guess some of the question
is like why is it so hard to make
progress and I think some of it is that
people like this Google engineer James
Seymour want to hold on to their
position they're in a position of
privilege and power and they don't want
to give it up and that's very
understandable like people don't like
losing things people want to believe the
meritocracy just as I did before they
want to believe that the system is fair
and the people that are succeed and want
to believe that they deserve their
success so it's very hard to dismantle
these feelings that are very deep down
even for the people that are very
committed to change it's difficult to
change culture and processes and these
things take a very long time so it's
hard to see immediate gains and
sometimes that can be frustrating when
efforts are being put out there and we
don't see immediate changes and
particularly in the in the startup world
where you're doing a lot of trade offs
long term versus short term if you're in
a start-up that only has so much runway
and you just need to ship your product
and get some customers it's hard to
prioritize diversity in the in that
short term but what happens then is that
you start to accrue this diversity debt
so similar to technical debt if you
start doing things in ways that aren't
sustainable it works in the short-term
because you need to get over that hurdle
you need to hit that product launch but
as that that accrues sometimes at some
point it becomes so much and you can
never recover from it and there are some
companies I've gone so far down these
paths it's kind of unclear if they'll
ever be able to fix their problems and
pay down that diversity debt it's just
it's easy to keep doing things the way
we've been doing them one example
something that accrues diversity that is
the way a lot of companies do hiring
which is based on referrals and it's
very easy to refer people from your
network that you know that are similar
to you they've worked it in the past and
bring them in it's very easy to get
going like that what happens then though
is because these networks social
networks tend to be very homogeneous you
end up just perpetuating the the
demographics of your initial teams and
the further along you get the harder it
is to to change that once your team is
thousands of people and they're still
doing all these referrals and everybody
looks very similar it's hard to ship
very hard in the other direction okay so
lots about problems would be nice I also
talked about solutions so a couple years
ago I and a few other women in tech who
would often get together and talk about
these issues were frustrated about all
the talk of problems as I just laid out
and we thought we should actually start
trying to focus on solutions and see
what we could do instead of having the
same conversations over and over again
and what came out of those initial
discussions a couple years ago was a
nonprofit called Project include which
I'm now a founding adviser to and our
idea was that we need to start giving
people solutions and there are people
who want to do the right thing and just
don't know what to do we were often
getting people asking us for one-on-one
coffee so we could give them a brain
dump on what they could do around
diversity and we thought it would make
more sense to be more scalable if we
actually just wrote down those
recommendations and try to compile these
resources to make it easier for people
but as we came together we also thought
about what it means to have sustained
solutions and ones that actually make
change in the long term and we started
with core values
the first of these is true inclusion and
this idea of not just solving for gender
first which often ends up being white
women first because of that proximity to
the power structures now think about
inclusion that actually encompasses
everybody so instead of just widening
your circles of exclusion getting rid of
rid of those circles of exclusion
altogether thinking about
intersectionality so it's not just
gender and race and class and religion
but all these things cross with each
other and all these different dimensions
of people's identities and thinking
through solving that in a very holistic
way we thought it was important that
there'd be comprehensive solutions that
are not just you know this tactic here
and this other tactic here people are
very into the idea of having a
three-point checklist of top 3 things I
can do they want to hear about things
like the Rooney rule which is just make
sure that you have some diversity in
your candidate pool and then that will
resolve in better metrics downstream I
just want to have these easy
check-the-box solutions but it's not
that easy of a problem to solve it's its
culture processes it's really deeply
ingrained power structures and I would
treat diversity analogous to many other
things that companies are trying to
solve and say around growth and try to
acquire our users monetization and sure
there are blog post with people say all
you have to do to solve culture is these
three things but that's never the full
story and people spend a lot of time
thinking about what are the different
ways that we can grow our consumer
software company there's always
different hacks you can try and lots of
Ben tactics you will read about from
other people but in the end you need to
have a comprehensive strategy and you
may be able to pick and choose some of
these different tactics from other
people but you need to think through the
problem holistically and the third core
value we had was around accountability
and that comes from metrics was we had
seen before not having any sort of
metrics it's very easy to say we're
working on the problem and never see any
gains we thought was important that
around diversity inclusion we're
actually setting goals and measuring
ourself against those goals and
sometimes we're gonna miss those goal
which is fine sometimes you miss your
growth targets or your sales targets but
doesn't mean you don't set them so
that's been very core to all the work
that we do and what we ended up doing is
as this group of eight people we just
wrote down everything we knew to be best
practice knowing that best practices are
gonna change and we're gonna learn more
about what works and what doesn't work
but we wanted to put a stake in the
ground write down those things and also
start to build a community around those
where we can update them so a little bit
like open source software where people
who are solving some problem will I'm a
writer I just offer put it out there
other people who want to who find some
benefit can use it if they make
extensions if they want to add to it
they want to help maintain they can also
be part of that community so thinking of
the diversity and inclusion work and
recommendations as almost like open
source and trying to pull in these
learnings from the community as well so
we have this resource out on the website
we also started doing more programmatic
work through startup include where we
actually have cohorts of companies that
come in and we help them to instrument a
lot of their diversity and inclusion
numbers so it's not just demographics
it's not just how many black women do
you have in engineering and how many
Hispanic men do you have in leadership
it's not just those demographic numbers
but also things like have included are
people feeling so the sorts of things
that people will study in engagement
surveys like does everyone feel like
they have the same chances to succeed do
they agree with the direction of the
company do they feel confident in like
where the product is going so we help
these companies to measure this data and
we're still building out those base
lines and those benchmarks but we think
it's really important that we start to
build community around this we also
recognize that we're a small part of the
ecosystem and there are actually a lot
of great people doing work in this space
some are doing it professionally so
there's a good number of nonprofits and
for-profits doing work and diversity and
inclusion I think sometimes it'll just
be hard to see change because these are
such hard problems and it'll take a long
time before we see success there are
also a lot of people who are working on
this as a second shift of emotional
labor on top of their normal jobs
people who are software engineers or
leaders and they just do this on top of
what they already do so I do think it's
important to give a shout out to those
people we just need more in that I think
ultimately tech leaders need to take
responsibility here because they set the
priorities diversity and inclusion even
though everybody says it's a priority is
not actually a priority of everything
else gets prioritized above it and if
companies are consistently prioritizing
speed of hiring over diversity and
inclusion like that is what's going to
happen in those companies so it really
has to be driven top-down I think you
can see some success from grassroots
efforts but really leaders need to take
on more of that responsibility I think
for people in this room and people were
listening to this later there may be
questions like well what can I do so
it's great to say like leaders need to
do certain things but what can I do I
how can I be helpful I think for
students you actually have a lot of
leverage as candidates that people want
to recruit one of my friends who's a
software engineer in industry said when
she gets recruiting messages she'll use
that leverage she has as a viable
candidate to ask companies hard
questions so things like what are your
diversity and inclusion numbers so
hopefully the company is tracking
diversity inclusion numbers and
hopefully they're good you can ask about
things like gender breakdowns or racial
breakdowns in engineering and leadership
on the board you can ask about things
like family leave parental leave
policies are you offering paid parental
leave above and beyond what's required
which is very little by the law one
interesting one that my friend asked
about is do you have trans inclusive
health coverage and it's difficult for
some of these people who are
marginalized groups to have to ask for
these things if you're in a position
where you have some privilege and you
can and you have some leverage and you
just ask these questions it helps to
tell companies that you care about this
and people care about this and
we'll help them to prioritize these
things as well it also just gives you
useful information about the company and
their culture and if you want to join a
company like that for people who are
looking to start companies or end up
being leaders and in companies you can
also use the leverage that you have to
ask these questions for example if you
are a founder and you're raising money
you can especially if you're a hot start
having people be seeds are trying to get
and you can ask these VCS about their
diversity including numbers and what
their efforts are there was recently
pledged going around founders for change
where these founders are asking the VC
firms that they may be taking investment
problems do you have female partners and
are you making investments in a diverse
set of entrepreneurs one of the one of
the projects I've been working on
recently is something called moving
forward and what we've been doing is
asking VC firms to publish
anti-harassment policies and points of
contact so this is a really basic thing
that came out of some the me2 movement
last year but realizing that a lot of
firms don't have guidelines around what
is appropriate behavior or not and what
can or what should be the follow-up and
what where's the accountability so we've
been asking founders when they're
talking to me you see firms to ask if
they have these anti-russian policies
and if not to join on with this moving
forward movement it's not a huge ask but
it does help to shift that ecosystem a
little bit for founders and people who
are leaders and decision making roles
you can hire diverse teams that make
make that a priority it's very easy to
hire from your networks
I know how it feels I want to hire
people that I've worked with before and
I know really well but I think it's also
really important to look outside your
networks and get more of that diversity
in the room and it may take longer but
it's worth it in the long term for
everyone not just the people especially
those people who are not from
marginalized groups you can use the
privilege and position that you have to
advocate for others one of the most
powerful things
is thinking about who's not in the room
and advocating for them and I see this
even in our diversity and inclusion
circles like in the people I work with
there sometimes we get very fixated on
the particular groups who are advocating
for us there's women in tech there's
black and brown people in tech and then
I also realize there's many people who
are not even represented in the room
because they're so marginal it's like
there's no native people in many of
these rooms we don't have a lot of
diversity of religion so we're not
talking about what is what is the
experience like to be Muslim in our tech
companies so there's so many other
people who are not even in these rooms
so that that exercise of thinking about
who's not here and can I try to at least
give them a little bit of voice or at
least call attention the fact that
they're not here how can we start to
solve these problems I think it's
important that we don't just let the
people who are from underrepresented
groups do all the work of trying to push
for diversity and inclusion that often
happens where the one women in the room
will be asked to do the work of
diversity plan this panel or invite the
speaker or mentor the younger people and
I think a lot of times those people from
underrepresented groups will feel some
of that burden to do that work and they
want to do it but it's also unfair to
ask those people to do all that work all
the time and so for those people who
have more bandwidth aren't necessarily
from those groups being able to spend
that time to advocate for others is
really powerful so it's a bit tricky
sometimes just you want to amplify these
voices that aren't heard as much and
help people help to bring people into
the room but you also don't want to take
up the space there so there have been
some cases of people who wanted to be
helpful but ended up hogging all the
limelight instead of giving the stage to
people who are traditionally
underrepresented or aren't getting that
stage time another thing that all of us
can do is push for just better processes
in general and you know it's startups in
particular it's pretty easy with their
often no processes at all so just
introducing some basic ones can be very
helpful around things like hiring
for example promotion when I first
started working at Quora and I was told
to interview people they just threw me
into room and told me to come out with a
yes-or-no answer which is very standard
for startups is like just go there's no
process yet but much better practice
would be actually having rubrics and
having criteria for what you're looking
for that helps to standardize it also
helps to remove a lot of bias so it's
been interesting academic research on
this
if you don't ask people to specify what
they're looking for upfront they'll let
their bias he's come in they'll justify
it later it was a really interesting
study about hiring for police chiefs
where people were shown resumes like one
of a man one of a woman and in one in
one scenario the man had more experience
the woman had more academic background
and the people were choosing with she
was a man and they were justified by
saying oh we want somebody with more
work experience like that's what this
job needs and then the other scenario
the man had more academic experience
women had more work experience they
still chose a man is that well we just
really need more academic experience in
this case so they went back into their
choices with these justifications but
when the people choosing were told to
write down their criteria ahead of time
they would be consistent with that so if
they said they wanted to have the
academic background then when they were
presented with the two resumes and the
woman had more of an academic record
they would choose her so there there's
actually a lot of really great research
about how do you can mitigate your
biases and some of these things are just
they just make more sense it's not just
about diversity and inclusion it's just
making these processes better so writing
down rubrics around not just hiring but
also promotion very valuable a lot of
times in companies when you're thinking
about who's gonna lead some new project
or who's gonna work on this like
interesting new opportunity there's not
a lot of process around it and people
would just think who I would I know who
might be interested in this who might be
good at this and we tend to fall into
the same biases there it's written out
it's like when we're choosing a tech
lead these are the things we're looking
for and this is our process we're gonna
look at everybody who's at a certain
level and has been in the company
an amount of time consider them then you
actually end up with a much better
decision and it has a side benefit of
helping diversity and inclusion people
from the underrepresented backgrounds
looking forward I think there's just a
lot of hard work that still needs to be
done in this space
a lot of stuff is unknown there are
decades of research on diversity and
inclusion and I think it's very
important that we look at what's been
done already what's been done in
different industries and all the
academic research but a lot is also
unknowns the tech industry is one that
moves very quickly startups are changing
all the time and we'll have to
experiment and figure out what works and
what doesn't work I think we can take
some of the same approach we have
towards building products and building
companies and apply it to things like
diversity and inclusion try out
different things instrument them look at
the metrics see what works doesn't work
iterate on it and keep trying so some of
the cool new things that are happening
for example are more companies or
playing with apprenticeship programs so
looking at having longer on rounds for
people who are coming from the less
traditional backgrounds but recognizing
that they have a lot of potential as
long as they're given the mentorship and
onboarding and that capacity to learn
I'm not everybody is going to be able to
be productive as an engineer after one
month on the job for example but some
people if you give them a little bit
more time they will be very productive
you just need a longer on-ramp so a few
companies are doing these apprenticeship
programs companies are trying different
hiring practices so in engineering for
example coding on the white board has
been a have a mainstay of software
interviews for a long time and companies
are starting to move away from that and
to things that are more representative
of actual on-the-job work so coding on
laptops with access to Google and Stack
Overflow which is more representative
job and in the interviews actually
assessing out how they would perform on
the job so I think there's a lot of
interesting room for experimentation
here and there cool companies working on
this I think there's a lot of things
that are in play right now and they just
haven't been running for long enough for
us to hear about them but I'm very
excited to see some of those write-ups
and what comes out there
another space that's really interesting
is looking at the intersection of new
technology fields and how they relate to
diversity and inclusion so a couple of
really hot spaces now for example our
blockchain cryptocurrency is an AI and I
think there will be unique challenges
for diversity and inclusion in those
fields for crypto for example it could
be a really cool new tool for inclusion
financial inclusion or it could be a new
form of digital colonization where we go
into these different spaces and tell
them like this is the new way you're
going to do banking and finance and not
including them in that so that's a
tricky one it's also this whole new
paradigm of of digitization where
economics are embedded in the technology
itself which is very different than the
early internet so it's kind of hard to
anticipate what's going to happen here
there are some numbers although none of
these numbers are very accurate there
are some numbers that say most of
cryptocurrency wealth is held by men
like ninety five percent is held by men
and that's going to have a lot of
ramifications when economists are so
embedded in the systems that are getting
built so there'll be new challenges
there kind of we get people in there are
some efforts that have been let's give
some of these coins to just everybody in
the community but the problem is for
people who don't know the space we don't
value the cryptocurrencies they
immediately change it to fiat currency
and cash out and the people who are the
believers are again holding all the
coins even if you've had a really
concerted effort to distribute them
initially so there will be interesting
challenges here with AI also really
interesting because we're thinking we're
looking at how our biases get embedded
in technology in products it's pretty
clear you know you have these
interactions on your on your website or
your your app and there can be biases
and what products are getting built but
what's even more dangerous about
something like AI is that there's bias
using the data and it's hard to even
examine what's happening there you can
have things like these runaway feedback
loops and we've seen some of this happen
with news feed on various social
platforms there's a really interesting
book on this called weapons of mass
destruction by Kathy O'Neill and she
talks about some of these models where
you know there may be some bias
originally and the data said some biases
and the heuristics are used for the
feature selection in the models but what
gets worse is when the outputs of these
models get used as inputs again and so
you start to see problems like using
these predictors for recidivism in the
criminal justice system and continue to
perpetuate the systemic inequities so we
have to think about ways to tamp down
those feedback loops and sometimes we
don't even understand that they're there
so there are researchers working now on
interpretability of machine learning
models which is going to be very
important going forward as the sorts
intersect with these domains that have
regulation you need to be able to
explain but there's technical work that
needs to be done and it's research so
it's hard to know where we're gonna come
out on that one thing that is also
promising about AI machine learning is
that we can also try to use it to solve
bias so there are companies like Tech Co
which helps you to look at your job
postings and see if they're they're
biased towards male or female candidates
and help you to remove those and suggest
alternates alternative words some
interesting research I was reading from
a couple years ago is some some models
over text data that were having gendered
relationships between things like you
know doctor and men and nurse and women
when they could identify the gender bias
they could also go into the models and
actively device and remove that bias
which is pretty powerful if you think
about it so with humans even if you
identify bias you can't really get rid
of it very easily people will
acknowledge that they have biases they
need to work on it but you can't just go
up and like zero out your vector and
make sure that all future decisions are
unbiased but you can do that with AI
models potentially depending on which
ones you're building if you know that
you want to intentionally remove the
biases here there's other research
happening and how do you decore elate
different things so say you're building
models and financial models you're not
supposed to use
race this is this is like actually
regulated in some industries so you're
forbidden from actually using races and
input to your models but there are proxy
variables so looking at tip code for
example you can end up basically getting
the same biases embedded and so there
are people working on how do we do
post-processing around the output of
these models to actively do you
correlate so there's a lot of really
interesting work happening and I'm
pretty excited that the technology
industry is just changing so much and
it's doing so much to set the direction
of our future and it's gonna change how
we interact with each other how we
interact with the world and so there's a
lot of really cool opportunity to make
positive change in industry or events or
venture capital where they're saying you
know I'm not gonna wait to be anointed
I'm gonna go start my own organization
and do it differently yeah there's
definitely a lot of these firms popping
up so in the venture world a lot of new
funds have female or minority partners a
lot of these funds also do tend to be
smaller though so the big the seed funds
or maybe serious a so they're starting
to make some change in helping
entrepreneurs to get funded at an
earlier stage but there's still a lot
more to be done there if you look at
total investment dollars going to female
founders it was still only 2 or 3
percent of total VC money so even if
there's some work being done in the
early stages and you can talk about
higher percentages of women getting
funded in the seed stage at the at the
later stages it's still pretty bad and
it's hard for founders of female
founders underrepresented minority
founders because they're still running
up against the gatekeepers of capital
now so then it might be easy to get a
little bit of funding early on but it's
it's still difficult
numbers yeah so two questions one is
should diversity be an end in itself and
the second question was what are the the
numbers that would be like a success
yeah it's a really good question on
diversity as an end in itself I think
people will have different responses to
this and some of the justifications
around diversity now are just very
commercially motivated in order to get
people's attention I think there are
justifications on the morale found like
we should just include everybody so it's
not necessary that diversity on your
team should be and in itself but it's
more the bigger picture like everyone
should have a shot at being a part of
this industry and we shouldn't have
these circles of exclusion so this is
what the moral argument do you think
about what opportunities are we giving
to people and on the on the business
side diversity has been shown to make
teams better in the innovation context
so if you want to be in innovation which
the tech industry is having diversity on
your team which means that they're more
creative they've been shown to have
better financial outcomes and just
generally produce better results which
also intuitively makes sense when you
have people coming from different
backgrounds they no longer carry
necessary the same assumptions they
realize that people may be approaching
things from a different way and they
work a little bit harder to justify
their opinions and their arguments so
it's just generally better for business
you think about the consumer case like
we're trying to build technology
products for everyone so it makes sense
have representation of those people in
the teams that are building and
sometimes you'll miss out on really
obvious things because you're lacking
those perspectives for example when
Apple healthkit first launched iOS 8 it
was just thing you could track
everything you track your steps you
could do things like your sodium intake
and like all these different quantified
self things but they didn't have period
tracking which is
for half the population a very important
form of quantified self that they've
been doing manually for a long time and
it seems like those kind of oversights
be less likely with more diverse teams
in terms of what would be kind of a good
goal to get to I think around gender
getting to 50/50 is the most obvious
success outcome and that's not just
50/50 representation overall that's in
leadership as well and all the
decision-making roles if we're looking
at startups it should be 50/50 and
equity and the cap tables look what
happens right now is a lot of times
companies will have women in the non
technical roles that support roles the
ones that don't get a lot of
compensation or equity and so even
though overall it looks great like 40 50
percent female and these companies if
you were to look at where the wealth is
actually going to be and the terms like
the equity it's still very very skewed
on race it's a little bit harder to say
because it's hard to know if you want a
benchmark to the city you're in which
seems like too small of a geography or
the state or the country or the world
right because a lot of Silicon Valley
for example has immigrants coming from
all around the world and a lot from Asia
and so a lot of times people will see in
Silicon Valley and in tech the Asians
are way over represented relative to the
US population where we're only 5% and
some of this is just written by
immigration so benchmarking to the world
might be slightly better in some cases
but still doesn't quite make sense if
we're primarily building for them you
know and for some companies like
primarily building for a u.s. audience
so I think it will depend for each
company on on the race ethnicity side of
things some of it will depend on the
target markets and so if you're if your
products the consumer product and it's
selling to a particular audience and
having more of those people represented
in your workforce is good but I don't
think there's a hard and fast rule what
the targets should be around race and
ethnicity we talk a lot about gender and
race because those are the easiest ones
to track and a measure and those are the
visible ones there's also many other
forms of diversity that are sometimes
even impossible to track or you require
self-identification
not everybody is gonna self-identify so
some of those are even harder but I
think it is important to acknowledge
that we just generally want inclusive
environments where everyone can succeed
and some of the visible markers will
give you hints at that in the back so
I'm an economist and we have very
similar issues and just go there in your
last point so about this idea of like a
typical for gender diversity about HIV
it's an issue that I knew think up this
book pipelines so it's pointing up the
Stanford daily numbers on like the
Stanford siestas my major is during your
class and it looks like it's about
saving both like 70/30 amends with him
so I just wondering maybe on your
comments do you have any thoughts about
how to get well women and other
underrepresented groups excited about
majoring so I've lots of thoughts on
pipeline because the first reaction is a
lot of times people will use the
pipeline issues as an excuse for not
solving later issues around retention
and inclusion this is the first thing
however there are actually pipeline
issues if you look at the numbers as you
were as you were and I think it's a very
multi-part problem there's people who
are doing really great work on the
culture side of things like movies like
hidden figures are great for getting
black girls excited about technology
when they see three black women who are
NASA scientists like helping to launch
you know
rockets so I think on the culture side
and that's important trying to mitigate
some of those stereotypes I make this in
pop culture I think movies like The
Social Network which came out in 2010
can be actively harmful because they
perpetuate the idea of like the nerdy
hacker sitting in their basement in the
dark
coding by themselves so that culture
piece is important I think drawing more
of the the link between what a field of
study is and what you can do with it is
good so in computer science and
engineering
he's often very unclear for little kids
like what they can do with this field of
study and this is a bit of a
generalization but a lot of little girls
for example are interested in helping
the world and doing good things for the
world so it want to be doctors and
nurses or veterinarians or teachers
because they know that this kind of
profession helps them to help other
people but they don't know that being a
software engineer could help them help
the world in a very scaled way to in a
very different way so drawing the link
between what it is this field does or
what it is this thing is and like what
kind of impact you can have can be
helpful oh this is a good a generalized
problems just like helping people
understand what are potential career
paths in this world and what can you do
with that I think there's also things
that are within the control like schools
and universities so I think coming into
Stanford we didn't have to declare a
major so you can have a lot a lot of
people who could potentially become CS
majors and in my case I chose not to
become a CS major for my undergrad
because I was so intimidated I think
there's now a lot of pretty active
efforts to think about how do we make
the curriculum more supportive how do we
make the environment generally better
some of the things that happen in
classes that I took at Stanford for
example were know one professor that
after we turned our problems that's what
asked us like how long did it take you
to his problem set zero to ten hours
raise your hand
10 to 20 hours raise your hand 20 30
hours raise your hand 30 plus hours
raise your hand and I took 30 hours to
do my problem set and like I didn't know
of other people were being truthful when
they raised her hand at 0 to 10 to 10
hours but it was very intimidating to
see that and it made me feel more like I
didn't belong there and it didn't occur
to me later until later that people had
very different calibration
self-calibration there are things like
there's just the examples that are used
with the programming assignments like if
they are interesting and relevant to
people's lives
people are more likely to want to do
them trying to filter out or to build
different paths people will have more
experience or luck less experience is
good so it's not easy to be intimidated
by the person staying next to you who's
been coding since they were eight that
happened to me with some of my
classmates who had just been coding for
a long time some I've done software
engineering internships when they were
in high school and
when I looked at them next to me I just
felt like there was no way I would ever
catch up it turns out that it didn't
take that much time to catch up it
probably would have been one or two
courses but I think splitting out those
people from different backgrounds is
helpful so people aren't getting the
wrong impression what's happening around
them so you know that that's not even
like that hard to do and it's not that
far away from like industry but people
will say well it's a pipeline problems
on people studying in universities but
there's actually not that far away we
could have solved that problem there
I think Stanford is that made pretty
good gains and cs on that front my year
graduating from Stanford Oh nine there
were three women in computer science so
now that it's 30% that's that's a pretty
big improvement obviously there's still
a lot more to be done yeah I use it you
frequently use phrases like privilege
and technology colonization and I'm
curious about how in your work you work
with those who are in more positions of
power instead of maybe labeling them as
you know you have too much privilege or
like you won't you because you're not me
you can't understand those problems yeah
so a question is about specific terms
like privilege and colonization and
trying to relate to people who may be in
positions of more privilege and
conveying to them sort of work that
needs to be done yeah it's a it's a very
tricky topic and I think ultimately it's
about building connections to people and
using things that makes using
terminology and examples that make sense
so if we're talking about
marginalization people feeling out of
place everyone has had some experience
where they've been out of plays like
they haven't felt like they belonged and
it's one that some people have everyday
walking into the offices but even for
the white men in tech they've had
experiences in the past where they
didn't belong and so being able to
connect on those friends is helpful
some people are further along in their
studies of these of these issues and
they'll know more of the terminology
other people aren't as far so using the
words that make sense in different
contexts is good also just like
generally on Novica philosophy of
advocacy and working with people there's
a whole range of people's opinions and
there's this whole spectrum I think on
the one end you'll have people who are
the advocates and activists already on
the other you have skeptics and people
who may actually be pushing back against
diversity efforts and then you also have
a lot of people in the middle that are
dispositional II inclined to help with
diversity and inclusion but don't have
all the language yeah I don't know they
don't have all that exposure yet I think
focusing on that middle group where they
want to do the right thing but don't
quite have the language yet or don't
quite know what they can do to be
helpful is probably the best use of
advocacy time and it's good to be gentle
try to create safe space where people
can say things and they may not have the
right terminology and they may say
things that are slightly incorrect but
helping them to work through that become
good allies it's like we're like I try
to focus and I think is a good place to
focus energy it's a great question the
question is about is there a cheat sheet
or checklist of things that everybody
can do it to help out so one thing
that's very difficult is to give one
checklist of things because everyone can
do different things and for different
people and different positions there are
different things that will be more
leveraged or not so if you're a hiring
manager there are certain things you can
do in your capacity as a hiring manager
to make sure that hiring is more
inclusive if you're an individual
contributor will be different again in
depending on who you are what experience
you've had that may also be different so
there's no one checklist I guess the one
resource I would call out his project
include
the nonprofit I co-founded we do have a
lot of resources on there and those are
just primarily focus on tech startups
but some of those things are
generalizable or you can take
inspiration from some of the
recommendations on there but the project
include resources are organized so
everything from how do you define
culture to implement culture - how do
you do training for managers and
generally how do you resolve conflict
and so there's a lot of tidbits in there
that may be helpful depending on who you
are and what kind of role you're playing
in your company or in the ecosystem but
actual hires no one has released those
that I have seen many holistic way I
tried to push some companies to do that
and got a lot of pushback on that so I
think there are legal concerns around
that around potential discrimination so
if there's any difference in the
representations of people in the hiring
pipeline to actual hires that's grounds
for discrimination lawsuits so a lot of
companies are very skittish about that
and they don't wanna put that out there
unless there's a very compelling reason
for them to do that I do think a lot of
companies look at it internally because
they want to see where the drop-off is
and if there's differences in like the
application pool to the referrals to
like the outbound but I think will be
hard to get that data publicly because
of the legal risks
yeah question is around big companies
that don't have diversity how do they
change to actually get it and this is
one of the challenges that is very real
right now like big companies can't ship
their numbers that much for companies
that are hiring very quickly and hiring
a lot relative to their current base of
employees they can ship their numbers
from very large companies or hiring to
fill attrition maybe a little bit of
growth but it's hard to change numbers
substantially one other thing I would
tell companies like that to look at is
the inclusion metrics and engagement
metrics so even if you don't have a lot
of diversity in your team right now you
can try to make the people who are there
feel very included and look at the
differences in inclusion metrics slice
by different demographics so do the
female engineers feel as included as
male engineers isaiah's confident the
direction of the company do your like
black women in these different functions
feel as good as the other people like
the white men in these functions so
there's interesting analysis you can do
there and those things can actually be
moved in the short-term without changing
hiring and I think that's something that
companies do need to look at a lot more
at it's very easy to do press around
your diversity numbers and these
demographics but what's arguably more
important is that the people who are
there feel supported and included and
they actually have a chance to do well
this was completely wonderful thank you
so much please join me in thanking Tracy
you